you
[Music]
to pin down exactly what you're looking
for when you look for a role but I mean
it's just basic principles like I mean I
always enjoy being challenged by
something and feeling that I'm doing
something that I haven't done before so
that's probably the main thing that I
look for is something that's that's new
to me in really good script writing the
story is moved along and unfolds through
exchanges of character and through the
characters talking and sort of learning
about each other rather than sometimes
in scripts you know you're just reading
pages and pages of exposition and
characters explaining the plots and
actually a much more interesting at an
holy just better way of writing is is is
without exposition and where the story
is just being told through these
exchanges of character
I mean yeah just just bad writing just
um when you read a script that's like
kind of written with cliches and
sentimentality is something that I
always you know I can never stand in
films if I feel like the script is
trying to emotionally manipulate the
reader in a way that you know I'm not
naturally feeling that I always that's
something that sort of I find pretty
off-putting
preparation for every role is slightly
different but you know that's one of the
really fun parts of the job is is
working out how you need to prepare for
something I mean four to play Allen
Ginsberg obviously was a lot of work on
the accent and the voice and a lot of
reading about his life and and just
working with the director on things you
know for something like the musical I
did in New York on Broadway you know
that was learning to dance or and sing
and lessons like that so I mean it's I
like that my job always requires me to
prepare for something different free
time but ultimately you know the way you
break down a script is kind of the same
you know what what is your character
want in this scene what is he trying to
what effect is he trying to have on the
person that he's talking to when he says
that line and and what is his overall
kind of objective and if you have a very
clear idea I think of what those three
things are well that seemed that seems
to work for me anyways
every scene presents a different set of
challenges I mean there are always that
these scenes that you you worry about
the most the ones with you know huge
kind of emotional shifts and and things
like that and you know they can be very
hard but those the moments that you just
have to trust the director and trust the
other actors you're working with and and
give of yourself and be as emotionally
open and available as you can the
challenging scenes are the fun ones as
well I mean that's the thing is you know
that it's important to say that you know
the the more challenging scene is in a
way the more fun it is because the more
of my job I get to do
I think I learned from people around me
because I'm you know I'm now working
with people who haven't worked on nearly
as much as I have worked on but you know
they have worked in a completely
different way and have been through
drama school or have worked with you
know improvisation in a way that I
haven't normally so there's always you
know I'm kind of always looking around
to try and learn from everyone if I
could give one piece of advice it would
be that let's you know learn as much as
you can about how you the type of acting
you want to be the type of person you
want to be on set because you know you
can you can learn as much about how you
don't want to be as how you do want to
be from watching actors sometimes and I
was very lucky to have an amazing group
of people around me to watch and learn
from growing up so I think yeah just
just sort of be a sponge and take in as
much information as you can
gary oldman was somebody that I was
lucky enough to work with then I was
very young and he gave me great advice
and is still kind of real inspiration
and also David Thewlis who was on Potter
as well and I should say imelda staunton
and watching how they all conducted
themselves on set as well as being great
actors and great professionals they were
also really great people and lovely with
the crew and and just you know that's I
definitely saw that as sort of being the
way I wanted to be
- director Kelly darlings I think is the
most amazing director of actors that
I've worked with and I think one of the
things he does really well is he rather
than saying you know I want you to be
sad in this moment I want you to be
whatever in the smoke he will come up to
you and ask you questions rather than
telling you what to do and so you arrive
at the answers yourself and sort of have
ownership over them as as they then
become character choices and they feel
more like they're yours rather than
something somebody else has imposed on
you so I think that's definitely
something that John does brilliantly is
just ask the right questions that's the
thing I'd never worked with before was
just that idea of what do you want out
of the scene and so working with that on
killer darlings for the first time was
really a very it sounds a very simple
tool but it's a very powerful one as
well and it's a really great just way of
approaching kind of every scene
always remember but if you're if you're
working on film set and you're lucky
enough to have kind of regular work on
sets then just remember how lucky you
are to be in that position and how
there's a ton of people that will cut
their arm off to be where you are and
kind of let that inform how you go about
your job but most actors treat every
Glover's it's gonna be their last
because it has the sort of permanent
fear that we all live in what I actually
think that's quite a good attitude to
have you know because it just it means
you'll always work hard and work for the
right reasons
[Music]